- What do you remember of
the night that we filmed?
(inspirational music)
Do you remember doing a
science experiment for me?
- Yeah.
We're gonna study the
reaction of baking soda.
- [Man 1] Hmm, how much
do you put in there?
- [Man 2] A little dab will do ya.
- [Man 1] K.
- And some apple cider vinegar.
You see how it fizzes?
- Mm-Hmm.
And what's happening there?
- Science.
(laughing)
(background chatter)
I'll try anything twice.
I'll probably take a
nice big shit after this.
(laughing)
- [Man 1] Are you too tired for the fire?
- No man, I got the fire, I'm ready to go.
- Do you remember what
we did with the fire?
- Played with it a little bit?
Oh, did we do some smores?
- Let's find out.
- Let's roast marshmallows--
- I do have marshmallows.
(laughing)
- Why not, do you have a stick?
- Marshmallows (mumbles).
You're gonna find when you
bite into that marshmallow,
it's not what you're looking for.
- You know like, I love comedy
but I don't really laugh
that much?
I don't laugh harder than
this in the whole show.
This is like my favorite--
- Oh, really?
We were having a good time.
- These are the biggest marshmallows--
- I know, they're really big marshmallows.
(laughing)
- Do you remember this?
- Uh-Uh.
- [Man 1] All in the
name of science, right?
- I've gone through two
marshmallows at this point,
and yours is still on there.
- Do you remember any of it?
- I just remember you burning yourself.
Oh, shit.
- What, isn't that what
I'm supposed to do?
(inspirational music)